there is a three or four minute clip of
an interview that donald trump
granted to jonathan swann an axios
reporter
and it is the stuff of legend it is the
stuff of horror it is the stuff of
nightmares donald trump saying during
this
interview that not only does he read a
lot but he comprehends what he reads
what he reads really really well better
than anyone that jonathan swann has ever
interviewed
or at least recently which is quite a
statement take a look at this
i wouldn't mind if it reached my desk i
would have done something about it
it never reached my desk because do you
read your recent brief i do
i read it a lot you know i read a lot
they like to say i don't read i read a
lot
uh i comprehend extraordinarily well
probably better than anybody that you've
interviewed in a long time
i read a lot i spend a lot of time with
at meetings
so is there anybody in my audience who's
willing to defend trump on this that his
reading comprehension is
is really really good by most reports
donald trump has
not read a single entire book
in decades in his entire adult life
which is like the last 50 years
i am not aware of any book that donald
trump has actually read cover to cover
people i know who have really good
reading comprehension skills
they never brag about reading
comprehension put quite simply like
anybody who has good reading
comprehension skills talks about the mat
the subject matter of what they read
rather than the fact that they're really
good at reading and understanding stuff
and this was only the tip of the iceberg
a bunch of other strange moments in this
interview and the story
really in the interview other than trump
claiming he can read well
which is a strange thing for presidents
to ever have to defend
the the real uh theme of this interview
is trump bending over backwards to
defend
not confronting vladimir putin about
anything uh take a look at trump here
explaining why he did nothing about that
entire russia russian
bounty story which i continue trying to
bring up
did nothing about russia arming the
taliban did nothing about anything
related to russia take a look
i i have so many briefings on so many
different countries
but this one didn't reach my desk
the reason i say this is is even if you
don't believe the intel this particular
piece of intelligence and there is
dispute
no doubt there is dispute in the
intelligent community about it your
former uh john nicholson former head of
forces in afghanistan said
and this is when he was working for you
that russia is supplying weapons to the
taliban
isn't that enough to challenge putin
over the killings of well we supplied
weapons when they were fighting russia
too you know when we were when they were
fighting when the taliban when
in afghanistan it's a different era well
it's a dif i'm just saying
so trump just erratically brings up
a completely different situation
unrelated to him
as president and putin now as president
and
their relationship this by the way
doesn't have to be anything more than
trump is enamored with putin you know
you have now
there's this slice of the left who's
getting a lot of mileage of saying oh
the russia gators the russia gators they
were crazy
all you know you don't you don't have to
be alleging anything here other than
trump we know is really impressed with
authoritarians the people he's impressed
with are
putin duterte kim jong-un
erdogan etc and there's no conspiracy
being alleged other than
trump's enamored with dictators and he
seems particularly enamored with
vladimir putin and he seems to be
finding any way he can
grasping at straws to defend not
being tough on putin not confronting
putin that's all that this has to be you
don't have to
allege some bigger conspiracy now later
in the interview jonathan swann pushes
trump
um and insanely sort of ends up having
to explain to trump what's going on it's
very bad and it exposes trump's complete
lack of knowledge of even
basic foreign foreign policy realities
but you surely heard that right
i mean it's well known in the
intelligence army that they're arming
the taliban
russia uh i don't know when you say
arming is the taliban
paying or they give us supplied weapons
and money to the taliban
i have heard that but it's never
again it's never reached my desk i mean
he said it on the record when he was in
russia doesn't want anything to do with
afghanistan let me just say about russia
trump has access to the not that he
necessarily is taking people up on it
but trump has access to the latest
and greatest intelligence in the world
and you can tell
that he seems to be hearing much of what
jonathan swann is bringing up
for the first time from a reporter or or
at least hearing it in a way that he has
to react substantively
then trump knowing that he's flailing
and failing
tries to give jonathan swann a history
lesson and it gets really awkward
russia used to be a thing called the
soviet union
because of afghanistan they went
bankrupt they became russia just so you
do understand okay
the last thing that russia wants to do
is get too much involved with
afghanistan
they tried that once it didn't work out
how wild is that right
uh but but to focus on the primary topic
here
donald trump has not confronted vladimir
putin about supposed russian bounties
for taliban killing u.s troops trump
hasn't talked to him about it
and trump clearly has no interest in
talking to vladimir putin about it
despite the fact that they've now had
at least one conversation since that
story came out it's a sort of
jaw-dropping lack of self-reflection or
even
an interest in understanding
what the circumstances are and just how
bad
it looks and it's hard to fathom that
this is the president of the united
states at least for a few more months
and hopefully no longer
sort of like a sixth grader listen i
remember there were times maybe not in
sixth grade but in middle school
where i wrote a book report about a book
i didn't read okay i admitted i
there were times when i did that that's
sort of the equivalent of what donald
trump is trying to do here now the very
last thing
donald trump says it never reached his
desk that this story of alleged russian
bounties never reached his desk
that definitely seems to be a lie
there's has been
widespread and specific new york times
and other reporting
which claims that indeed donald trump
was briefed multiple times about this
and he just did nothing now i've given
you the timeline in the past
arguably as many as three or four
different times over the last year and a
half or so
where donald trump was briefed about
this new york times reported that trump
got written briefing in february of 2020
now that's just
you know five six months ago in a
presidential daily briefing trump in
this interview claims he reads it
so a sort of clever question because
jonathan swann gets trump to at least
claim he reads his pdbs
we know that this was in his pdb in
february now
cnn says that trump was briefed
somewhere in the area of
march april may on this and then
associated press sources
uh quote top white house officials
who say trump was made aware of this in
early
2019 a full year earlier than the new
york times and cnn say so
it's it's not just lies it's not just
being
enamored with putin it's also
either incompetence or a complete lack
of memory about the fact that he was
allegedly briefed about this multiple
times
or a sort of all-of-the-above scenario
but there's no
i mean it's you know either you care
about this stuff or you don't either
you're concerned about having an
incompetent buffoon
as president or you're not tens of
millions of people are not and they're
going to be voting for another four
years of this in just a few months
so if we want to prevent that from being
the outcome
we know what to do there's no i don't
have to give you any kind you don't have
to understand mechanical physics or
string theory or anything to understand
what the the thing is
you've got to vote everybody's got a
vote that's it if you are anything like
me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video